ارتقى عاليا في الهواء ليرفع بلاده الى
مربع الذهبي في كاس العالم
نتحدث عن يوسف النصيري مهاجم المنتخب
المغربي بضربه الراسيه بعد الارتقاء
الارتفاع مترين و 78 سم كتب نصري وكتيبه
اسود الاطلس اسمهم اسم بلادهم والعرب
وافريقيا بين افضل اربع منتخبات في العالم
انصيري اصبح اول لاعب مغربي يسجل في
نسختين من كاس العالم وسجل المهاجم هدف
الفوز الوحيد على البرتغال في ربع نهائي
قطر
20/220 وسبق ليوسف انصيري ان دخل التاريخ
مره اخرى سابقا حين سجل امام كندا واصبح
اول لاعب مغربي يسجل مثل ما ذكرنا في
نسختين مختلفتين اغلى بطولات كره القدم
لنتعرف عليها اكثر ولد هذا الشاب يوسف
انصيري في الاول من يونيو عام
1997 بدا مسيرته في شوارع وازقه مدينته
فاس التي انضم الى فريقها نادي المغرب
الفاسي
اعين مكتشفين المواهب رات يوسف انصيري
الذي انتقل عام 2015 لنادي ملقى الملقا
الاسباني الذي قدم بين صفوفه ثلاث سنوات
الرحله الاسبانيه لنصير استمرت بانتقاله
الى نادي ليغانيس صيف 2018 واستمر معه
لموسم ونصف فقط تالقه دفع بنادي اشبيليه
للاستثمار به والحصول على موهبته في يناير
من عام 2020 اما مع المنتخب فقد بدا مسيره
يوسف او بدات هذه المسيره بالظهور امام
البانيا والديا
المشاركه في كاس الامم الافريقيه في نفس
العام يوسف النصيري لعب 54 مباراه في
مسيرته الدوليه مع المنتخب المغربي وسجل
بها 16 هدفا
ربما يكون الاثمن فيها هو هدف الامس الذي
منح المغرب بطاقه العبور الى نصف نهائي
كاس العالم في قطر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]